hello and welcome video north hampshire
is the opponent and place a dutch
defense okay it looks a lot like he's
angling for the classical dutch it's
really very popular opening in in in
britain probably also due to the efforts
of simon williams this played it a lot
with really great success okay um let's
just support this a little bit yeah it
is a downright weird opening by
classical standards it just looks
terrible but it has practical chances
obviously we if you look at williams
results with it yes it's beaten like
everybody with it voyeur shack Gelfond
even so cool off it's like a fantastic
what he what he has achieved with this
opening so let's see i'm going to
reroute this to t3
I mean that opening is definitely better
than it looks that that's the thing I
mean let's see okay he wants to play 94
I guess okay I'd like to go f3 an event
that doesn't work at all and the age
three maybe it's a bit weakening it's a
bit weakening
I'm not very happy with this but 94 was
a threat
I mean I don't have a very clear plan
here what to do got nice space and
everything but what exactly is white
splenium don't know
no kg4 it's not g4s not a threat and
just go here chief why I've got f1 and
sorry I've got h4 see shooting for f4
here okay let's see if I can open up
things here yeah it will be over a super
super sharp position probably in no time
yeah it's got lots of stuff on my king
side but I couldn't really do much
against this interesting
hmm
it's got very interesting nights they're
quite it's quite irritating and heights
on c4 and d3 and in general we've got
all pieces on the board it's not a
single trade up to here not not a single
porn
Knight a5 USS Bishop c 8 mm that's not
helping at all okay he goes for them for
the PSAC on edge form yeah I have to
what is not clear i have to necessarily
take now probably i have to do that
let's get g3 coming
okay let's let's do this it's probably
very dangerous to take the bishop again
you can just go back actually maybe you
can just go back and there are
sacrifices that might be very strong but
just going back Bishop e7 is probably
not so bad
or down okay let's see if I can open up
things here a little bit then it's still
a bad
I is just slow that's the main hope here
a position is pretty bad
okay so one night age 32 doesn't look
doesn't look some threatening actually
we should take skin edge to that should
be rather save check night it's safe now
okay Bishop you five maybe okay um the
ship tanks gay won't make it make it
timewise the position now is ok but that
was really really bad time we had a
really bad position black forfeits on
time yeah it's the classical Duchess
tricky and it's also one of those
openings that you it's right you never
study you don't get it on the board and
you always think okay I should look at
look this up at one time and you never
do and then you're stuck in something
like that yeah he played that it's a
good alternative for sure the game the
game continuation was certainly okay fun
I mean around here he sees messing that
all those pieces on the Kings side and I
have my doubts the computer says like
gives gives wide an edge but it's very
difficult very difficult to say how much
you can trust the engine in this
position because it's similar to the
Kings Indian sometimes there are so many
pieces near White's King the computer
sometimes just does not evaluate that
correctly it still gives wide a net
share 0.6 0.7 but I mean look at this it
looks scary it really looks scary those
two nights and
my king position long and okay i played
here and this is already causing the
computer to I and it says it says that
don't believe that Bishop takes h4
shouldn't be good for black the engine
is not that convinced it wants to take
it wants to take care but this this
looks I mean more than dangerous 95
coming up engine wants to go night f/4g
3 and now the evil is going down and now
it gives black away now it just takes a
couple of a bit of time it just it's
just hard to dangerous this attack yeah
okay I actually I went here just to see
that it's not coming that quickly and
the the computer wants to take now and
sacrifice him gives this line
the slight advantage for black whatever
that means that funny it's a total mess
I had one of the craziest positions i
have had in a long while and the
computer is giving 0f it's cool and here
we are here it says i'm winning with
taking individual a 3-wood with what i
actually played so i didn't i didn't
play it that badly i mean i asked i got
into a bad position but check from from
that I defended reasonably well he had
say it's winning yeah yeah the classical
Duchess this kind of opening if you if
you if you study it and really know what
you're doing it can be a very dangerous
practical weapon I mean but God does
offer the objective merits it's just
dangerous it's really dangerous okay
thanks for watching